[Musique]
Olivier Paco nous nous accompagne pour
commmencer cette émission pendant une
demi-heure vous êtes sénateur de loise
apparenté au groupe les républicains du
Sénat et je précise que vous êtes
professeur d'histoire géographie et de
profession c'est important car on va
parler de la question de l'école mais
d'abord on commence par la loi
immigration des dizaines de milliers de
manifestants ont défilé hier dans la rue
contre ce texte qui ét voté par le
Parlement en décembre dernier est-ce que
cela peut convaincre le Président de la
République de revenir revenir en arrière
sur cette loi
immigration je ne pense pas il y a un
parlement qui s'est exprimé alors le
Sénat hein de façon approfondie
concertée l'Assemblée nationale avec
effectivement des épisodes un petit peu
chaotiques la loi a était votée elle est
maintenant déférée devant le Conseil
constitutionnel avec la volonté affirmée
du président de la République de voir
certains
articles éventuellement revus moi je
vais pas commenter une décision qui n'a
pas été prise par le Conseil
constitutionnel
néanmoins cette loi elle répond à une
attente d'une grande partie des Français
on parle de loi immigration mais
l'intitulé exact c'était une loi qui
avait pour but de contrôler
l'immigration et d'améliorer
l'intégration parce que il faudrait
d'une mauvaise foi totale totale pour
affirmer qu'il n'y a pas un problème
d'intégration
d'une partie de la population immigrée
dans notre pays aujourd'hui c'est pas le
seul problème que rencontre notre pays
mais on ne peut pas nier qu'il a un
problème donc cette loi a pour but de le
résoudre est-ce qu'elle résoudra tous
les problèmes je n'en suis pas convaincu
mais je pense sincèrement que pour
beaucoup de points par exemple la mise
en place de quota pour être clair par
exemple le fait de pouvoir renvoyer plus
facilement des immigrés qui se
comportent mal ce sont des points
positifs bien sûr finalement on
l'impression que le gouvernement attend
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
pour obtenir un recul sur certaines
mesures qui sont critiquées les
opposants à cette loi parle de
préférence nationale notamment sur des
prestations sociales qui ont été coupées
aux étrangers pendant une certaine durée
d'ailleurs est-ce que cette mesure ça
favorise l'intégration alors concernant
la fameuse préférence nationale je suis
curieux d'attendre d'entendre plutôt
l'avis du Conseil constitutionnel
puisque si on va jusqu'au bout des
choses c'est pas une préférence
nationale il s'agit pas de nationalité
puisque ces aid àocation familiale
àocation personnalisée d'autonomie
seront ou serait conditionné conditionné
à une résidence régulière et stable dans
le pays ce qui existe d'ailleurs déjà
hein les conditions seront légèrement
durcies néanmoins il ne s'agit pas
d'exclure totalement des gens de
certaines prestations parce qu'ils sont
étrangers il faut simplement qu'il
vivent en France depuis un certain temps
il contribuent fiscalement depuis un
certain temps alors les appels par
exemple on pourra en bénéficier au bout
de 3 mois est-ce que c'est scandaleux
non on rappelle qu'on parle des
prestations sociales non contributif qui
sont pas basé sur contrib tout à fait
alors Gabriel le Premier ministre a
promis dans les prochaines semaines
peut-être le mois prochain et bien la
présentation d'une réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État ça veut dire que la
bataille n'est pas finie sur ce sujet de
l'immigration et les républicains espère
beaucoup de cette réforme de laame de la
part du gouvernement écoutez laame était
dans le texte initial la réform
de laame de l'aide médicale d'État pour
des raisons tout cas dans le texte des
sénateurs les républicains exactement
pour des raisons de
diplomae parlementaire dans le cadre de
la commission mixte paritaire cela a été
ressorti mais il y a une promesse écrite
de la première ministre ellisabeth borne
de reprendre ce sujet via un texte de
loi écoutez que sa promesse soit tenue
Gabriel Atal s est engagé nous
reviendrons sur ce sujet c'est important
c'est important parce qu'il ne faut pas
que certains Français qui ont du mal à
se soigner et l'impression que
l'étranger qui vient d'arriver soit
mieux pris en charge que lui et là ce
serait l'inverse même de la préférence
nationale et je veux terminer sur la
préférence nationale parce que c'est un
sujet qui est méconnu en fait vous savez
le mot préférence nationale il a été
popularisé par le Front national mais il
a existé dans la législation dès les
années 30 avec des gouvernements de
gauche c'est la loi Rio de 19 32 et le
sacrin Front Populaire a utilisé la
préférence nationale a même renforcé
avec un ministre de l'Intérieur qui
s'appelait max dormoi et dont la
politique n'aurait pas aurait fait pas
lire peut-être géralde Darmanin merci
pour ce petit rappel historique Olivier
P on va parler de la colère du monde
agricole et on va retrouver nos
partenaires du journal Le Courrier
Picard avec Jean-Marc chevaucher bonjour
Jean-Marc bonjour alors effectivement
vous consacrez des pages à cette colère
du monde agricole qui monte de ces
dernières semaines avec notamment des
manifestations ce weekend et ça devient
une urgence pour le
gouvernement alors euh oui on a
l'impression que le le monde agricole
est est peut-être contaminé par la par
la colère venue d'Allemagne et puis euh
et puis se dit que doncant qu'ils sont
encore un peu nombreux ils peuvent ils
peuvent peser dans l'ouise
particulièrement en ce qui nous concerne
euh nous nous nous savons que euh le
département est l'un euh des plus
agricoles hein puisque il représente 12
% des fermes la totalité des fermes qui
sont dans les haut de France en plus de
ça le l'Oise est un département avant
tout céréaliers donc c'est vraiment un
département qui contribue énormément à
nourrir la France il y a encore 3200
exploitations dans l'Oise il y a
368000 hectares ça représente 60
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
ma question et pour Olivier Pacot sera
simple vous qui connaissez bien le monde
agricole on a encore
7500 actifs dans l'Oise à peu près la
moyenne d'âge est de 52 ans pour les les
patrons les les les chefs d'exploitation
de de agricole dans l'Oise alors
Monsieur Paco après vous avoir dit
bonjour ce que je n'ai pas fait d'entrée
je m'en excuse je vous je vous demande
que croyez-vous que puisse faire pour
pour garder euh spécialement dans l'ois
qui est quand même très grand
département agricole euh notre notre
filière agricole comment peut-on faire
pour pour encourager notre filière
agricole dans
l'Oise alors ce que l'on peut faire
c'est par exemple faire voter par
l'Assemblée nationale un très beau texte
qui a été voté par le Sénat pour
défendre la ferme France un texte récent
hein qui a été porté notamment par mon
collègue Laurent duup plomb pour
effectivement permettre aux agriculteurs
de vivre de leur travail on peut aussi
stopper ce qu'on appelle l'agribashing
nos agriculteurs font un travail
formidable ce sont des gens courageux là
on l'a vu au moment des intempéries et
de la neige qui venait déneiger dans nos
petit village c'était les agriculteurs
puis en même temps ils nous nourrissent
ve dire la problématique agricole c'est
une problématique de souveraineté
alimentaire donc on a besoin de cette
agriculture et aujourd'hui alors en
Allemagne mais aussi partout en Europe
nos
agriculteurs lanc un SOS et même plus un
ralbol il ne supporte pas de devoir
constamment s'adapter à des normes de
plus en plus
contraignantes tout en devant faire face
à la concurrence souvent déloyale de
produits importés de l'étranger très
concrètement le bon sens a été
guillotiné au nom de l'écologie on leur
impose des normes qui sont qui qu'il
respectent le plus souvent mais qui leur
coûte très cher et à l'inverse on va
faire venir des produits qui vont les
mettre sur la paille aujourd'hui on
continue à exporter he notre balance
commerciale agricole est excédentaire
grâce au vin mais on va importer des
produits comme du poulet des fruits des
légumes qu'on pourrait produire chez
nous mais qu'on fait venir du bout du
monde ou du bout de l'Europe à des coûts
inférieurs on marche sur la tête on
marche sur la tête c'est une question
aussi d'aménagement du territoire voir
si nos agriculteurs mettent la clé sous
la porte c'est une bonne partie de la
ruralité qui mettra la clé sous la porte
c'est inacceptable parmi les les motifs
de cette colère agricole il y a la
décision du gouvernement d'augmenter une
taxe sur le gazol non routier est-ce que
le gouvernement doit revenir sur cette
décision écoutez les agriculteurs ils
payent de plus en plus ce qu'on appelle
les intran enfin beaucoup de de de
choses qui leur augmente leur coût de
production ce qu'on appelle le GNR
effectivement régulièrement chaque année
le gouvernement veut supprimer les
exonérations puis régulièrement il
revient dessus donc peut-être que le bon
sens l'importera donc il faut revenir
sur la suppression de cette exonération
exonération fiscale non il faut que
cette exonération soit maintenue pour le
monde agricole oui c'est ça c'est ça
bien sûr d'accord bien sûr il paye déjà
assez de charges comme ça quand vous
voyez le tête de liste du RN et le
patron du parti Jordan Bardella qui est
quasiment vraiment en campagne quand il
va voir les agriculteurs et il dit c'est
la faute de l'Europe C situation des
agriculteurs il a raison en partie mais
c'est l'Europe elle a toujours bonau la
France surimose remet des normes
supplémentaires hier j'ai vu un
reportage très intéressant dans lois
justement concernant les ha vous savez
que on avait enlevé les ha ce qui a eu
des conséquences dramatiques en matière
de ruissellement en matière aussi
de de congère quand il neige un petit
peu donc on en remet maintenant sauf que
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi il y a
une dizaine de textes qui régissent la
la coupe l'entretien des ha on marche
sur la tête hein les agriculteurs savent
très bien quand ils peuvent et quand ils
doivent tailler leur haie laissons-les
tailler leur haie ça paraît
abracadaamenta ce que je vous dis c'est
la vérité merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
chevaucher pour votre intervention on va
regarder la une du Courrier Picard
aujourd'hui qui est consacré et bien un
accident un très gros accident à 23
blessés après un carambolage sur
l'autoroute A16 dans la Somme merci
beaucoup Olivier Pacot on va parler du
sujet de l'école he je précise que vous
êtes professeur de profession et
notamment de l'affaire qui touche
l'école privée catholique Stanislas à
Paris il y a actuellement une enquête de
police en cours pour homophobie et
sexisme concernant un intervenant de
l'école privée Stanislas cette enquête
de police elle fait suite et bien au
rapport très très critique de
l'inspection de l'éducation nationale
sur cette école Stanislas est-ce qui il
faut suspendre le contrat d'association
avec l'état de l'école Stanislas je
connais pas suffisamment le sujet
Stanislas pour vous en parler la seule
chose que je veux vous dire on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment oui oui on en
parle beaucoup effectivement il y a un
intervenant qui visiblement a
effectivement tenu des propos qu'il
n'avait pas à tenir il a été je crois
suspendu bon donacte faut-il aller plus
loin et bien l'enquête le dira toujours
est-il que moi ce que je tiens à dire
c'est qu'il ne faut surtout pas rallumer
une stupide guerre publique privée au
niveau de de l'éducation euh je suis un
pur produit de l'école publique mes
parents étaient untitte euh je suis
professeur de formation mon épouse est
directrice d'école un de mes fils est un
untite euh mais je suis le premier à
dire que nous avons besoin de l'école
privée ça fait partie de notre paysage
euh d'institution scolaires depuis euh
des siècles en fait euh avec par exemple
la loi Fallou ça fonctionne très bien ça
correspond aussi à une partie des
attentes de certains parents n'allons
pas allumer une guerre totalement
inutile et ce qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est que cette école privée elle rend
service en fait au monde scolaire je
vais vous donner un exemple très précis
dans l'Oise j'ai été pendant 2 ans et
demi vice-président du département en
charge de l'école ou plutôt des collèges
il y a 80 collèges dans le département
il y en a une vingtaine de privés s'il y
avait pas c un collège privé s'il
fallait les construire ça coûterait un
argent fou que nous n'avons pas et les
subventions que donneent les
départements ou des municipalités aux
écoles privées sont capés très limité
par ce qui s'appelle la loi fallalou et
donc les parents qui ont choisi de
mettre leurs enfants dans le privé sont
des contribuables sont des contribuables
il y a rien de choquant à ce que cette
école fonctionne et la dernière chose
qu'il faut dire quand même c'est que
aujourd'hui ce que recherche les parents
qui mettent leurs enfants dans l'école
privée c'est pas une école religieuse on
met plus ses enfants dans le privé pour
des raisons religieuses on va chercher
dans l'école privée et c'est ça le
paradoxe et un peu le drame de l'école
publique on va chercher dans l'école
privée d'aujourd'hui l'école publique de
jadis c'est-à-dire une école où la
méritocratie où la discipline le respect
de l'enseignant sont des valeurs
cardinales on a compris on oui on a bien
compris votre pldoyer pour ce système
école publique école privée la liberté
scolaire toujours une question sur
l'école Stanislas ce qui est ce qui lui
est reproché également et bien c'est
d'avoir organisé un système de
contournement des règles de parcours sup
la plateforme d'orientation vers
l'enseignement supérieur un système qui
permettrait au lycéen de Stanislas et
bien d'être accepté dans la classe
préparatoire de l'école Stanislas un
système dont a bénéficié le fils de la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale Amélie
UDA casterra qui est et bien empêtrée
dans cette affaire depuis et bien 10
jours maintenant est-ce qu'elle peut
rester en poste moi je vais pas appeler
au à la démission de madame cterra
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'elle a été assez
maladroite dans sa défense pour être
ministre de l'éducation nationale faut
peut-être avoir un minimum d'expérience
j'ai été très surpris de le voir
arrivver à ce ministère je vous le dis
très franchement hein en tant que
ministre des sport elle avait des
compétences une expérience sportive qui
lu permettait de bien exercer la
fonction l'éducation nationale c'est
autre chose sincèrement elle a agi en
tant que parent ses choix sont les siens
je ne souhaite pas particulièrement
qu'elle démissionne mais elle a brillé
là elle a pas brillé après pour revenir
à votre question sur le contournement de
parcours sup si tel est le cas
effectivement il faut que les choses
changent parce que il faut qu'il y a un
minimum d'égalité entre les lycéens de
notre pays et le système parcours sup il
est suffisamment compliqué en tant que
sénateur avec d'autres j'avais pu
dénoncer ces incohérences des fois ces
injustices donc si si si c'est
réellement le cas il faut que Stan
revoit sa copie Olivier PAC on va parler
des questions internationales et du de
la guerre entreis Israël et le Hamas
puisque les sénateurs travaillent sur ce
sujet ils sont même allés sur le terrain
en voyage en délégation on en parle avec
notre chroniqueur parlementaire Quentin
[Musique]
Calmet bonjour Alexandre bonjour Olivier
pacoon bjour Quentin alors Quentin
Olivier Paco faisait partie d'une
délégation de 22 parlementaires et des
écrivains également qui ont été reçu en
Israël au début du mois de janvier
exactement il est des périples qui
marquent bouleversent transformment
c'est avec ces mots Olivier Paco que
vous avez raconté votre voyage vous
étiez en Israël effectivement du 7 au 10
janvier dernier vous avez notamment
rencontré le président de la cisset le
parlement israélien des responsables de
l'armée des Affaires étrangères mais
aussi des parents d'otage parmi les
sénateurs français de votre délégation
on a vu sur ces images de i24 news le LR
Francis spinner ou encore les centristes
Olivier Olivier sigolotti vous avez pu
visiter un des kibuts c'est c'est ça
qu'on voit en ce moment déciimé le 7
octobre dernier celui de karasa un des
29 kibuts ou village attaqué autant
d'Oradour surglan en Israël avez-vous
écrit le 7 octobre est un des jours
noirs de plus après le 11 septembre et
les Twin Towers le 13 novembre et le
Bataclan dans la guerre de civilisation
mené par l'islam radical contre
l'Occident et ses valeurs c'est ce que
vous avez écrit dans votre communiqué et
donc c'est ce qui voilà marqué selon
vous votre voyage alors cette visite de
parlementaire et bien elle fait suite à
un autre voyage celui du président du
Sénat jar Larché qui était accompagné et
bien en décembre de tous les autres
présidents de groupe politique au Sénat
exactement Public Sénat les a suivi ces
sénateurs ont visité le même kibuts que
vous voyez cet extrait du reportage
réalisé par notre journaliste audreé
vetaz en la sablement les militaires
racontent ces vies qui se sont arrêté le
7 octobre comme celle de
était réfugé dans chambre
sécurisé le Hamas incendé toute sa
maison il avait 18
ans c'est le commandant GL qui chargé de
l'idenier parle ses yeux fixent le sol
comme s'il en avait trop
[Musique]
vu pas é entre normalement dans ce
Kib
des personnes ont été brûlé vives une
fois nous avons cru qu'il n'y avait
qu'un corps à identifier mais il y en
avait en fait trois Olivier Paco 63
personnes ont été assassinées à karasa
comment décrire ce qui est un cataclysme
pour la société
israélienne le 7 octobre c'est une
résurgence de la Choa c'estàdire que en
l'espace de 3 He il y a eu 1400
morts pour faire une comparaison avec la
France c'est comme s'il y avait eu 10000
français exécutés en donc en 3 Hees donc
le traumatisme il est incommensurable et
Israël
aujourd'hui doit entre guillemets rendre
impossible une nouvelle résurgence et
c'est pour ça que tsal mène une guerre
méthodique dans la bande de Gaza avec
effectivement
des conséquences vis-à-vis de la
population civile qui sont dramatiques
mais ce qu'il faut vraiment bien
comprendre est ce que je pense beaucoup
de Français ont du mal à comprendre
c'est que le Hamas cette ce groupe
terroriste qui dirige Gaza le Hamas a
déclaré une guerre pas seulement à
Israël il y a pas que de l'antisémitisme
et de l'antisionisme ils haïsent tout ce
qui peut représenter nos valeurs
c'est-à-dire la démocratie la liberté
d'expression c'est-à-dire l'égalité
hommes-femme et donc quand je dis que ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre est une
suite du 11 septembre 2001 et du 13
novembre 2015 oui il y a une guerre de
civilisation qu'on lancé les islamistes
radicaux le Hezbollah al-qïda daesh et
évidemment le Hamas et donc on ne peut
pas regarder ça en condamnant les
méchants israéliens qui ne font que se
défendre alors effectiv il faut qu'il le
fasse avec mesure mais c'est très facile
à dire de loin et ce qu'il faut savoir
je je tiens vraiment à le dire c'est que
quand les Israéliens vont bombarder ils
préviennent ils envoient des
tractes en demandant aux populations
civil gazaou quand elles le peuvent de
partir comme les Israéliens ont évacué
leur zone frontalière sauf que le Hamas
exécute je ne l'avais pas mis dans mon
article le Hamas exécute les Gazaouis
qui veulent partir et donc les Gazaoui
restent sur place et malheureusement ils
deviennent des martyres brandis par le
Hamas Olivier PAC on va on va écouter le
président du saintagar à l'archer au
moment de la visite de ce
kibut après
avoir
marché marcher dans dans ce kibuts il y
a quelque chose d'extraordinairement
émouvant pour nous don nous avons le
devoir de porter témoignage nous
entendons là où nous sommes actuellement
des bruits de tir et nous savons que il
va falloir que demain soit construit
Olivier Paco vous avez écrit dans votre
communiqué qu'il n'y a pas de paix
possible sans disparition du Hamas estce
que cet objectif est militairement
possible l'éradication de ce groupe
terroriste qui est infiltré dans la
population de Gaza c'est très difficile
mais vous savez nous avons vaincu
l'Allemagne nous avons fait la paix avec
l'Allemagne en 1945 à partir du moment
où les nazis ont été éradiqués alors il
y a toujours des né nazi dans le monde
il y en a toujours mais il y a plus
d'État nazi il faut plus qu'il y ait
d'État islamistes comme il y a pu y en
avoir en Syrie voilà donc effectivement
la pine est pourê pour faire la paix il
faut être deux ou trois ou quatre mais
tant qu'il y a le Hamas il peut pas y
avoir de paix israël veut la paix Israël
n'a aucun intérêt à vivre dans une
guerre permanente et les Palestiniens
méritent la paix comme ils doivent avoir
un état il faut qu'il un état israélien
un État palestinien évidemment ça me
sert le cœur de voir tous ces civils
Gazaoui qui meurent mais aujourd'hui
tant que le Hamas est là peut pas y
avoir de Pai il reste une minute Olivier
Paco on voulait évoquer bien sûr le
sujet des otages c'est un sujet qui est
essentiel depuis le 7 octobre à Tel Aviv
une place est dédiée à ces otages avec
une grande table et 132 couverts et un
mot d'ordre bring them home voilà qui
est donc dit sur qui est sur toute les
lèvres on a même vu dans des
mobilisations encore ce weekend en
Israël vous l'avez vu vous cette cette
mobilisation de la société israélienne
on pense à ces otages effectivement ah
oui je suis allé sur cette place je suis
allé à la cissette où des familles
d'otage étaient réunies pour exprimer
leur volonté d'une trêve d'un cesser le
feu c'est très difficile de trouver le
juste milieu j'espère qu'un cesser le
feu prochain permettra effectivement de
nouveaux échanges comme il y en a eu
échange entre otage et prisonniers
palestiniens bien sûr il faut tout faire
pour ça il faut faire revenir le plus
possible d'otage il en reste à peu près
129 malheureusement certains sont morts
on le sait mais il faut qu'il revienne
le plus possible c'est un traumatisme
pour les Israéliens merci beaucoup
Quentin pour votre intervention merci
beaucoup Olivier PAC d'être venu sur ce
plateau ce matin